oh my goodness we're at 109 degrees
Celsius on here M1 Max versus M2 Max
it's not really that big an update right
well I think you're gonna be surprised
because today we're gonna compare
everything from some benchmarks real
world tests we're gonna look at The
Thermals and see how hot this powerful
chip gets and we're also going to look
at battery life because when you have
this many cores you can suck some power
so let's go ahead and get right into it
now starting out both these systems are
at 100 battery life and I'm gonna unplug
them right now because we love to see
these realistic real world battery tests
not just what the manufacturers claim
now I do have them in high power mode
because we want to get the best
performance but in the future I'm going
to test out the low power mode and see
just how good these extra new efficiency
cores are now here are the full specs of
the machines they're priced exactly the
same with the same amount of RAM and SSD
space but of course you can get the M1
Max version for quite a bit off up to
four or five hundred dollars less so
we'll see if you should just save the
money and get the older one now one
downside is the HDMI port because the M2
Max version can support up to AK 60 or
4K 240 hertz compared to 4K 60 so it's a
lot more future proof and with that the
Mt Max MacBook has Bluetooth 5.3 and
Wi-Fi 6E now I upgraded my router and my
internet to test out how much of a
difference does it make and I was
shocked when I went from 705 megabit per
second to
1099 and get this that's not even using
Wi-Fi 6E that's using Wi-Fi 6 on the new
one and I tested both so if you guys
want to see the full breakdown and how
much of a benefit you get and also some
downsides make sure you guys are
subscribed now with that I also want to
let you guys know about our giveaway
that we're doing of a 14 inch MacBook
Pro and a Mac Mini me tomorrow we are
going to be announcing the winners in a
video so make sure you guys comment down
below all I need to do is comment
subscribe and enable notifications for a
chance to win now most other things with
these laptops are the same we have uh
the same display with that 1600 nits
same design same weight but one thing
that reviewers didn't mention is that
Apple did change up the speakers and
probably for the worst let's go ahead
and take a listen
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
mic set up uh can pass this through
through YouTube's compression but the
old MacBook actually has brighter highs
and a little bit more volume than the
new M2 Pro now Apple's doing this across
all their MacBooks the 14-inch the new
M2 the 13-inch MacBook Pro they're
toning it down and I don't know why
because I prefer the old one now another
thing that we have noticed with the 14
inch model is that the heatsink has
actually gotten smaller at the same time
as we have more cores so let's go ahead
and open these up and take a look inside
here and as you guys can see see the
actual heat block once again just like
the 14 inch is a lot smaller this on the
side here is literally just a little
plastic sticker over a little metal
frame but the actual block is this top
section so it is probably what about
even half the size here looks like even
an even bigger difference comparing the
14 inch M1 Pro to the M2 Pro that is
crazy now we will see if Apple changed
anything with RPMs of the fans and the
thermal performance does this get a lot
hotter and does it thermal throttle
we'll see in a second but another thing
we notice is that the actual SSD memory
module chips here they are a lot larger
on the M1 Pro smaller on the M2 Pro now
both these are ones terabyte so maybe
they're using a different manufacturer
or something else that's changed even
the contact pads are a lot smaller so we
will do an SSD test now before we
compare the SSD speeds I've got to talk
about the best maxi iPhone case I ever
seen the magic stand case from our
partner case coup not always a
surprisingly slim and durable but it
comes with a very strong 48 Magnet Maxi
freeing that actually doubles as a stand
just pull out the ring to use it as a
finger grip or a stand for watching
videos at any angle between 40 and 120
degrees and the best part is that it
folds completely flush with the case so
you can still use it with your max save
Chargers and accessories so use the link
below to get a special discount today
and now let's go ahead and hit run we're
using amorphous disk Mark which gives
you a lot more information and right in
the get-go check this out our read speed
is actually faster on the old one with
those larger chips but as far as their
write speed the M2 Max actually wins now
here is the full comparison and other
than that first read speed the m2s ssds
win especially if we look at like the
large block randoms now one thing I will
say if you are buying a 512 gigabyte
model in that case just don't do it
because you're gonna save a little bit
of money but that is half the speed of
the one terabyte M2 whereas the previous
M1 Max laptops the performance didn't
really change so it's definitely not
worth saving that 200 for 512 do the
3500 one if you're buying that spec it's
well worth it now another thing that
reviewers didn't mention is that there
is a difference in terms of the webcams
this is the M1 Max 16 inch MacBook Pros
1080p webcam and microphone and while it
does look good this M2 Max MacBook Pros
looks better it is sharper has more
detail the colors are a little bit
better and I think looks more pleasing
and as far as the microphones I can't
hear myself right now but you guys let
me know if you notice any difference and
now let's get into the performance and
when you notice something crazy our M1
Max is running at 3.2 gigahertz just
like like the M1 Pro but the M2 Max is
running at
3.67 much higher whereas the M2 Pro runs
at 3.49 or so so Apple's clocking the M2
Max in the 16 inch higher and we'll see
if it can maintain that speed when we
run some more tests now I'm personally
curious will the 14 inch M2 Max also get
this higher clock speed we'll find out
when we compare the 14 inch to the 16
inch so make sure you guys have
notifications enabled and now I'm going
to run this test alright guys look at
this we have a single core score of
2067. that's the highest we have ever
seen definitely beats out the M2 Pro as
you guys can see right here compared to
1782 that is a difference of 16 whereas
when compared the M2 progress M1 Pro we
added 10 difference so that is sweet the
extra clock speeds are helping now in
terms of multi-core score we have a
difference of about 18 not 20 like apple
advertised but this multi-core score is
the best we've ever seen for this
machine with this Ventura update I can't
wait to see if it's gonna keep that up
but first we're gonna run speedometer
2.0 web browsing test so many programs
are online now and so you need good
performance both of these are good but
the M2 Max gets 441 18
higher web browsing performance which
for some of you guys that will matter
for example web design with figma we
have this project right here that our
partners 500 designs gave us which are
some of the best designers out there and
when I zoom in and out everything is
really really smooth on the M1 Max let's
check out the M2 Max
also nice and smooth I'm going to go
ahead and zoom into this section right
here see how long it takes for things to
refresh so super super quick definitely
seems quicker than the previous laptops
we tested and it's almost instant when I
zoomed in there let's check out this one
here
definitely taking nowhere to be longer
to refresh this was maybe a second even
less almost instant this one about two
so I don't know if it's the clock speed
helping or what but what I'm going to do
is I'm going to export this website we
have 12 high resolution layers there all
right we are done and the empty Max took
a minute and 34 seconds compared to a
minute and 55. so that's about 20 faster
with the M2 Max now we usually don't do
this but I have to figure this out I
have cinebench open and I'm going to
start out by running the single core
test because I need to know about the
3.7 gigahertz so let's go ahead and hit
run I have pseudo acetop opened up right
here and look at that that is very
disappointing why is it doing that
the world we have high power mode on I'm
running the single core test and this
thing is only running
at 3.26 gigahertz compared to 3.24
basically the same that is crazy Apple
had to wire these differently now Apple
usually runs the M1 Pro and then One Max
uh the same they've always had the same
clock speeds but now I took out
the 16 inch M2 Pro not the max I wanted
to double check and here single core is
running at 3.5
gigahertz Mt Pro the M2 Max it's running
at 3.2 3.30 right there just hit 3.3
went back down
and Apple's using more of the efficiency
cores they set this up differently it's
running slower than it is actually rated
even the M2 Pro so let me close this
down I have one more thing to try our
friends from tuna belly made this
endurance Benchmark and I can actually
select just one core so let's run it on
both once again we're getting 3.2
gigahertz basically the same on both of
these that is crazy the crazy thing is
that this uses Apple's own terminal to
load the cores so the clock speed is by
Apple's design that is insane now let's
just go ahead and test out the full on
multi-core and see the performance that
we get now I'm not only going to run a
single test to see the regular
performance but we're going to do the
thermal throttling test as well because
I've been noticing that the M2 does run
hotter pretty much all the time right
out of the get-go we could see that we
are using about six Watts more on the
CPU of course we have the extra two
efficiency cores and all of those are
larger as well running at 91 degrees
compared to 83 that was quick and we got
a score of 13 888 for the M2 Max
slightly higher than the M2 Pro and
that's a difference of 21 right in line
with what Apple said but just so you
guys know when you're running we're
seeing that 3.2 gigahertz not 3.7
gigahertz that shows up and it seems
like the only place that really helps is
for geekbench to get some higher
Benchmark numbers but if you guys know
more about that let us know and now
let's start the throttling test I wonder
if we're going to maintain that 21 gain
we can see we're running at 35 watts
compared to 28.29 so a lot more power
used and the temperatures are also
higher and Bam we hit 100 degrees
Celsius 101 on the M2 Max for some of
these performance course 102 while the
fans are just starting to turn on that
is crazy while the M1 Max is running
quite a bit cooler we are looking at 95
degrees compared to 105 and it's crazy
to see that the fans on the M1 Max are
literally running as slow as they
possibly can while still being on so we
definitely are seeing a thermal
difference so we're almost done here and
I'm gonna check out the heat with my
thermal camera we're seeing about 42
degrees Celsius on the M1 Max
and about 42 degrees Celsius as well on
the M2 Max but the Heat's concentrated
way more in the center there because we
have that smaller heat block now the
other thing that's really standing out
to me is that Apple has changed how
they're doing stuff I think it might be
with Ventura because the M1 Max now runs
really hot after a while
um we're running at one of the cores at
103 degrees Celsius another one is at
100 and 201 over here we're running very
similarly uh so they've tuned this to
actually be quieter but run hotter now
the other thing I notice is that even
though the fans are running slower on
the M1 Max model I actually hear it more
so it has a higher kind of pitch sound
so I don't know if they changed up the
fans or whatever but they're running
faster but still quieter which is good
now one really cool thing with TG fan
Pro is that you can set your own curve
so you can bypass apples and if you want
to run the fans more than 10 20 or
whatever is on this chart and you want
to keep your Mac cooler you could do
that I'll leave a link to it down below
so here's our scores and the difference
is still 21 so we had no issues with
throttling at least if you're maxing out
the CPU now could be another story if
we're doing a task that uses both the
CPU and the GPU and there are real world
tasks that do this while we're running
at 108 degrees Celsius now I turned on
3D Mark as well to max out the graphics
now here we're also running hot but it
took a lot longer and the fans are
starting to kick on but the CPU actually
is down clocking uh on both of these
ones right now let's wait for the fans
to kick up Apple's way too slow with
this oh my goodness we're at 109 degrees
Celsius on here the fans are ramping up
loud you guys could probably hear them
and these systems are any hot now this
one the M1 Max look it's down to 100
degrees Celsius
99.98 but here we're still running hot
you guys can see those crazy
fluctuations in power fluctuations in
the frequency both of the fans are maxed
out
but now the M2 Max sounds louder at full
blast the M2 Max is way more erratic
going crazy here trying to maintain
performance at its Max compared to the
ammo Max a lot more chill maybe it just
has to do with the extra cores the
smaller heatsink but we'll see what we
get for the final cinebench score we're
almost done here and the M1 Max is at
41.
40 yeah 41 there
and here we're at 44.
yeah right about 44 degrees so
definitely running hotter all right guys
we are done and we have
9161 for the L1 Max definitely drop
there and 11 036 for the M2 Max that's
the difference of 20 percent
so yes it ran hotter it ran louder it
was more erratic but at the end of the
day even though I had to share power and
thermals with Graphics the performance
difference was still 20 what Apple
claimed it was so uh that is fine but we
do know if it had a better cooler or if
it was three nanometer in that case the
performance would maintain itself quite
a bit better and overall I would say a
yes it will thermal throttle but for
most people you don't have to worry
about it and now let's test out the
graphics performance it's a huge reason
why people want to buy the M2 Max with
38 cores compared to 32 for the M1 Max
and it looks like we have a difference
of 32 percent in favor of the M2 Max so
that is right in line but let's do
something that is a little bit tougher
because geekbench doesn't scale the best
this is 3D Marks Wildlife Extreme Gaming
test in case you guys want a game on
your Mac back after work is done we have
121 frames per second compared to
150.8 now that seems like a pretty big
difference that's only about 25 a little
bit underwhelming and now I'm testing
gfx benches Aztec Ruins 4K and we have
139.5 FPS compared to
179.4 that's a difference of 29 so we're
definitely getting better scaling here
so 25 to 30 percent better but now let's
go ahead and test out some productivity
tasks for all the coders out there we
are going to run our xcode Benchmark and
I wonderfully be able to see those
higher frequencies and that took 75
seconds compared to 90 that's 17
faster now the weird thing is that our
M2 Pro 16-inch did that in 70 seconds
and I ran it another time just to make
sure we're getting the same result and
running again and trying to look at
clock speeds it's just moving around a
little bit don't know what's up with the
tuning what's going on uh but I wish it
was better and now for those of you guys
that work with music we have our new
logic pro Benchmark turned on here which
has a lot of tracks different plugins
and one thing we've noticed is that the
M2 series of chips don't really perform
better than the M1 when it comes to
logic looks like the M1 Max just got
overloaded the M2 Max is still going so
it looks like we reached 170 tracks on
this one 174 here very little difference
and either way both of these are great
but if you're thinking about upgrading I
wouldn't do it and now it's time to test
out blender 3D rendering using metal I
have the classic BMW test opened up
right here let's go ahead and render wow
the M2 Pro took 21.8 seconds compared to
40.18 almost twice as fast and this is a
simple test so let's make it more
difficult this is the party tug demo
file and there are a lot of shaders and
uh a lot of different lighting it's a
lot more difficult as you guys can see
the gpus are maxed out on both of them
and once again the M2 Max is nearly
twice as fast a minute and four seconds
compared to a minute and 50. now the
graphics should only be 25 30 faster but
this has also got to do with the extra
caching in the M2 Max chip a lot larger
buffers and it definitely helps a lot in
blender so if you're somebody that needs
to have a laptop for blender this is
definitely a reason to upgrade next
let's get into photo editing and I want
to start out with affinity photo 2 and
it's very well optimized and they have a
built-in Benchmark and here as far as
the CPU performance increase for Vector
tasks we're seeing about a 13 difference
not that big and for graphics the M2 Max
is 24
more powerful and it's slightly
underwhelming and this program is
already so optimized I think it's not
really worth getting the Mt Max now as
far as Photoshop I'm using the latest
version that came out recently and
performance has improved but that
doesn't mean that you still don't have
to wait so I'm going to be compiling an
HDR image here I'm going to do this one
by one to make sure I test it correctly
and it looks like the difference isn't
big at all we have 27 seconds compared
to 32. now as far as Lightroom classic
it has already been fast on the M1 Max
now this thing also uses a ton of GPU
now and memory it also uses the neural
engine so let's go ahead and select the
sky and see which one is quicker
wow the Mt Max is about three seconds
faster there it's almost half the time
that was impressive let's try that one
more time for good measure we have the
shot of the hot air balloon that I took
let me click the subject button here see
how long it takes to find it
okay that was very fast for both of them
and now I'm gonna export these 50 edited
raw images the M2 Max is definitely
flying here but the M1 Max really sped
up there at the end and we have a
difference of just six seconds 39
seconds compared to
45. so far it seems like for photo
editing there's not much difference but
I have one more test I want to run I
have 10 50 megapixel raw images for my
Sony A1 and I'm going to do a panorama
here they did a great job this thing is
super high resolution and the M2 Max is
16 faster 42 seconds compared to 50 once
again not huge so I will say it's not
really worth spending a ton extra for
the M2 Mac let's go ahead and take a
look at video editing this is what we do
most and I'm hoping we have a big
difference now the M1 Max already does a
really great job with standard 4K files
even with Luts and film grain applied so
I want to know did Apple change the
encoders with this new chip will it
export faster for the kind of footage
that most of us work with and it looks
like they're pretty much neck and neck
which is a disappointment now I'm not
going to do a ton of video editing tests
I'm going to do a separate video also
looking at Premiere Pro and DaVinci
Resolve and different codecs if you guys
want to see that make sure that you are
subscribed but after this easy one we'll
do a couple more tougher ones wow a
minute and 15 seconds for both of them
incredibly incredibly fast set encoding
but we did not get any difference with
the M2 Max so unless you just have tons
of layers tons of effects and you're
maxing out your GPU you're not going to
see a difference with standard footage
now the sweet thing about these machines
is that they have prores decoders and
encoders in my Mac Pro I spent two grand
for a card just to decode prores so what
I'm going to do is see did they get any
faster let's hit export there and I want
to mention that the encoders were
already super fast we were typically
limited by the graphics performance and
here I'm seeing a very very slight
difference I was honestly expecting more
and we have 43 seconds compared to 46.
that is crazy I mean both are fast and
apple doesn't seem like they changed too
much there so we'll do one last test
this is 8k red raw footage and it's very
tough at full quality as you guys can
see neither one is playing back
perfectly but it's close and of course
you can go into better performance to
make it play perfect I'm gonna export it
into a 4K file for the web let's get
started now this is only a one minute
clip here because five minutes takes
quite a long time here but let's see if
we notice any sort of a difference and I
really really hope that we will as you
guys can see the graphics are fully
maxed out on both of these systems but
as far as the CPU the M1 Max has to use
more of the CPU uh but not significantly
so this just has more performance more
cores so it's using a little bit less
the M2 Max took a minute at nine seconds
compared to a minute and 22 roughly 15
faster uh we're not limited by encodas
or anything it's just the raw
performance and once again I really wish
it was better than that because CPU is
20 faster gpus 30 uh sometimes more than
that percent faster but
um that's not that good now I really
want to test out the latest version of
Premiere Pro and DaVinci Resolve DaVinci
is very well optimized so if you guys
want to see other codecs denoising
Blackmagic raw and how those programs
compare I'll have a full detailed video
for video editors so make sure you guys
have notifications enabled once again
comment below on this video and others
if you want a chance to win a 14-inch
MacBook Pro or the Mac Mini we're going
to announce that on February 1st and let
me know is it worth upgrading or if
you're just trying to buy one would you
buy the M2 Max model or should I save
some money on a discounted or used M1
Max model we also have the YouTube
shopping feature you guys can click that
and you guys can check check out both of
these machines and now I just want to
show you guys the battery life last we
have 12 on the M1 Max and six percent on
the M2 Max only a difference of six
percent you guys saw this uses a lot
more power but it also has the new
efficiency course that are much more
powerful so Apple can use those instead
of performance cores more often plus we
have four instead of two which means
that the easier tasks offset the big
extra wattage that was used in these
tough tests in this video we did a lot
of tough tests so overall you're not
really going to suffer on battery life
very much and for easy usage well in
that case you will actually gain battery
life now I want to do a dedicated
battery life comparison with low power
mode which just uses efficiency cores uh
and then some other tests if you guys
want to see that make sure you guys also
are subscribed with that little button
button above go ahead and check out one
of those great videos right over there
let me know your thoughts below this
with Max and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]